the Gus's gonna thank you very much for
your question asking what's the most
interesting either you've led at the
World Economic Forum well for me it was
a statement made by a Chilean Minister
his name is felipe kast
Azam who he talked about the Equality of
dreams now I think that sums up really
what the World Economic Forum is trying
to promote that everyone must have the
opportunity to dream equally and only if
you can have opportunities can agreement
to have what everybody else also has now
that was a very powerful comment and I
know that and I wish this world could
provide every citizen of the world the
Equality or trains